all right Sarah
were you from originally where'd you
grow up
um I'm originally from Boulder Colorado
um and
and grew up there until I was about nine
and then moved to California with my dad
and family
tell me about your relationship with
your parents
um well I'll start with my mom because
uh she has she passed away in 2014.
um
her and my dad
were married when they were 19.
she it was actually an arranged marriage
she's originally from Guyana
and she was studying in Saudi Arabia
actually on a scholarship she got when
she was 16 and um
she was extremely intelligent
um
and she left my dad when I was five
years old and
um
things got extremely complicated after
that
um
yeah my relationship with my dad is um
at this point is uh
it's non-existent
um I mean
last year I saw him
after my grandmother his mother passed
away and
um
I did have a talk with him
about some of the stuff but um I asked
him to just
kind of leave me alone
um
and he asked for forgiveness but like I
just didn't really feel that
it was meaningful
or that he actually
um
that he wanted to have a conversation
about it it was more just like
you know he just wanted me to forgive
him for religious purposes and kind of
move on and like not have to think about
it and
I didn't think that was fair and so I
just told him that I needed him to leave
me alone and give me my space and I
haven't talked to him
since then and actually it's been like
um
it's been a bit freeing and
not having to think about it is is nice
not having to think about him tell me
what's going on with your dad when you
were young
um When We Were Young okay my dad joined
a cult when I think I was still a baby
and
um you know growing up in it that's not
like how we Define it obviously
um I grew up mostly with my dad
when my mom left
um
she was basically kind of labeled as uh
a devil
um for for leaving the group and for
like wanting to have a life outside of
the group
um you know she she wanted to become a
nurse which she did she went to nursing
school
and she became a stewardess and at first
like we kind of saw her on the weekends
and then
um it got less and less and then my dad
like
remarried twice
um and
I was basically separated from my mom
um a lot of my childhood most of my
childhood
um he thought that
again she was evil and
um
that she would influence me
so I I spent a lot of time thinking
about you know where she was but not
really able to to see her
so I grew up mainly with with my dad
until I was about
12 years old what kind of cult was it
it was a Sufi cult
um
I'd rather not say the name but it was a
Sufi cult they were they're
International
um they started they they started a
larger group here in in the United
States in California and my dad was a
big part of that
um that's kind of why we moved to
California so like the um
there's a grand Shake internationally
and then there was a shake that was
appointed here to the United States and
he started the group in Palo Alto
um
I think it was like around
1990 or something like that and
um
it you know kind of on the outside of it
people would get drawn in because it was
like meditative and
um it was all about love like you know
you know it's like religion equals love
and love is God and
um so you just have to you know follow
that path
um and so people kind of got hooked on
that and
um they have what they call like you
know weekly thickers where they do
chanting kind of so it falls in the vein
of like um roomy and Sufism
and so they did like a lot of chanting
and
um
inside of that structure there was
another structure there was a bit of a
hierarchy and the more money that people
had in the group
uh the more status that they had within
the group and the closer they were to
the shake and like basically that
guaranteed their place in heaven
depending on how much you know
money that they that they gave
and basically whatever
if you did not have money then you had
to give something else whether it was
like working
um whether it was you had to dedicate
yourself in some way right and
um so there were a lot of people there
working for free
um my dad
help to build that group he helped build
their online presence and
um
he was a software engineer and dedicated
most of his free time to you know
building
that group and being kind of like the
Shake's right-hand man I think maybe he
didn't have as much money as the other
people but he did have a lot to offer as
far as his work ethic and you know he he
had a vision that he wanted to see this
this group succeed and he was very
dedicated to that
what do you think was really behind this
cult this this religion
uh like everything else money money
power
money and power
um yeah I think that's those were the
main motivations for
um the the cult leader and his family
and
I've seen that to be true after many
many years of like processing this
um obviously when I was a child I just
you know I was I was told very strictly
to just obey not question
um you know basically like
the shake was considered to be like a
descendant of the Prophet so like he
could do no wrong his family could do no
wrong
um even if they were abusive towards us
even if they
um did bad things like you know God will
look the other way and um
if they did bad things to us then
that was our fault
and the shake was from what country
um
I I don't I don't know if I want to talk
too much about that
okay
this went on in your childhood for how
long
um I was well for for most of my
childhood and until I left
until I left yeah
you left when
I left when I left my my ex at 23 years
old
um my mom
had my mom left my dad and she never
believed in this group and she thought
it was a cult and I think you know she
tried to tell my dad that even though
she had also an Islamic background but
she like she grew up with it it wasn't
like an identity crisis for her
um I think
they just had very different views on
religion
um
and she she was a free spirit
um she just
uh she became an atheist
what kind of things did you go through
as a young girl
being involved in this
um well I guess um
I guess there's layers okay so there's
there was my relationship within my
family which was
um
which was problematic and then there was
the relationship with the with the group
itself and So within my family
my dad remarried twice like I said the
first wife that he married
um
she was extremely abusive
to me and
um and and my my brother I had two
Brothers
and
um my mom used to see us occasionally at
that point and she would she would drive
from Boulder to Colorado Springs to pick
us up like every other weekend and um
you know I was about I want to say it
was about five and she came and picked
me up one time and I was like kind of
bent over and
um my brother was not doing too good
either and she pulled up our shirts and
just saw like a lot of bruises and um
she immediately took us to the police
station
and um reported it and because of that
like
I think my dad had to get a separation
from that woman
and um
and I feel like my dad blamed us because
of that
you know because you know because he had
to get a separation from her
and
um
then we didn't see our mom as much and
my Dad decided to remarry again and he
uh one day he just picked us up from
school in a big van and he was like
we're going to New York and um
again I probably was like
want to say seven
I can't quite remember I was probably
around seven and we drove across the
country to New York where the grand
shake like the shake from International
came
um to visit in the U.S and it was like a
big deal for for the group a lot of the
followers were going to be there and my
dad wanted to be there and
he got married there to a woman who had
five children my stepbrothers and
sisters and
um
and at first it was like really exciting
because like I I got brothers and
sisters and it was like oh this is gonna
be awesome you know like I just remember
when we first met my brothers and
sisters who I'm still like super close
with most of them um
you know we were jumping on the bed and
uh
it was fun it was I was having a good
time you know it was like a really fun
time that I remember and
um
and then we drove back to Colorado
Springs
and that's really when things got
extremely extremely abusive in my dad's
household
um he
at that point in time you know the shake
in the U.S was not here it was like
there was a small group in New Mexico
and
um
you know there were different folks that
were a part of this group
um and um it was pretty insular and that
in that they had like their own school
for the kids and
um
things like that but anyways my dad was
connected closely with this group we
would we would go visit New Mexico quite
a bit and I think he connected with some
guy out there and um he also had step
kids
and I don't know man it seemed like
maybe they were into like torturing kids
or something but um my dad just became
extremely extremely abusive
um we didn't see my mom during that time
at all like she tried to come and see us
one time
and I just remember her coming to the
house
and
um she was yelling outside I want to see
my kids I want to see my kids and I was
at the window like you know the second
floor and I was looking down and I
really really really wanted to see her
so bad I hadn't seen her in so long and
um you know I was crying and then she
she threw a rock at the window she broke
it because she wanted to see us
and my dad called the cops and she got
she had to leave
and after that you know I feel like I
was blamed in some ways like why were
you crying for your mom I just remember
being asked that and um my brothers and
I were were really punished after that
and it was like this Narrative of that
you know my mom was a really bad person
she was the devil
and she was influencing me somehow and
because of that I needed to be punished
um so basically
my brothers and I were isolated from the
rest of the family
um
we were put in our own room we were like
we were basically accused of anything
that went wrong in that house and there
was like nine kids in the house
um
and so we were just constantly being
abused by my dad
um
you know uh
the food was used as punishment we were
basically deprived of food
one time for a whole week
um
physical abuse belts
just uh just we were I just remember
just be living in just constant constant
fear
why did your mom not
try to
was your mom powerless I guess my mom
after she
you know after she threw that rock or
whatever I don't I don't know I I just
know that I didn't see her do you feel
abandoned by her
um I think
I told myself that my mother loved me
because
my dad often told us that she left
because she didn't love us
and so I knew that he was lying about
that and I just I knew that my mom loved
me I just didn't know where she was
um
I guess I probably did feel abandoned by
her um I don't it sounds like you might
have been confused though yeah I was
confused I wanted to see her very badly
of course and
I mean you know his divorce was
obviously not easy on me and I really
wanted to see my mom
um
I wanted to be with her
I did not want to be with my dad
um he was just
you just turned into like an extremely
mean person and uh that was not who he
was like earlier on but then he just
like turned into this like really
extreme
um
sadist I felt like he was a sadist I
mean it was just very
it was like there wasn't just no emotion
with him and um the the pi like it was
just I just
was constantly afraid of him and so
things kind of went on that way
um there were a couple times where I
talked I was like trying to talk to my
brothers to see like who he ran away
you know between the ages to seven to
like eight
to nine as which is when we left
Colorado uh I was just trying to like I
think I was just trying to survive but I
did try to
um we did try to run away we got caught
and then we got in trouble again for
that
um
I I
um one of my teachers
at school I'll never forget her she uh
she called me one time and just like
during a recess she said can you come
and talk to me and I I sat down with her
and she was like what's going on at home
and um
I told her
and uh I think she probably called you
know uh CPS or something
um and I and I just remember getting in
really big trouble after that as well
and
um
in um 1990 like right at the beginning
of 1990 we ended up moving to California
my my dad got a job out here in uh in
the Bay Area and uh all of us moved
and
um at first I thought you know like oh
maybe the abuse is going to stop but
you know eventually it just continued
and
finally when I was about
um
like 9 10 I was sent to live with like
various
people in the group
and finally with my grandparents but
during that time when we were in
California the the group became a really
significant part of
of our daily lives so we would either be
at my dad's house school or at the at
the uh
what they called the Durga or the the
Masjid
or the shakes house so I was sent to
live with my Mom
finally at 12 years old
and that was after spending a couple
years with my grandparents and um
at that point my mom was just uh
she had become a pretty bad alcoholic
she was working as a nurse but she was
also drinking she was a functioning
alcoholic
um
it was great to be reunited with her I
loved her very much but it was extremely
difficult to live with her
um
and I
at school I it was kind of up and down
junior high and my freshman year of high
school I decided like halfway through to
really buckle down and it was because of
one person
um who told me that he thought that I
could become a lawyer and he was like
you would be a great lawyer and that
kind of like really changed
my world view because like up until that
point I don't think anybody who really
told me that I could do something with
my life
and so I
I cut a buckle down I was getting I
managed to pull up my grades and
that semester I had started seeing a boy
who was he was like
he played basketball and I saw I met him
during a basketball game and we were
hanging out and
um you know
it was it started to become like you
know he was my boyfriend my mom found
out about it
and she told my dad
um you know she didn't really know too
much about what happened when we were
living with him and maybe she thought
like
he needed to know I don't know why but
he asked that my brothers and I go visit
him that summer
in California
so I was living with my mom in Denver
went to visit him
for the summer and right after getting
off the plane he basically told me like
um
you can't have sex outside of marriage
that's completely against the religion
you're going to go to hell
he would go to hell like you know
everybody in the family would go to hell
so that just wasn't allowed and I had to
get married
um the you know the shake was gonna pick
who I was going to be married to
and that was the end of the conversation
um
so we came here to we came to Los
Angeles uh for a um a conference a
religious conference that he had put
together with you know the group and it
was it was it was pretty well attended
um and um
it happened at the Westin Bonaventure
and
um that morning one of the mornings
during the conference my dad told me to
go talk to some guy who's sitting in the
coffee shop
[Music]
um he was like 28 years old
um I didn't know him but he just told me
to go over and talk to him and I
remember sitting down having a
conversation I just ordered a glass of
orange juice and I was just looking at
my hands because we were basically like
told not to look at guys we couldn't
look at them in in the eyes it took me a
long time to be able to look a guy in
the eyes
um but
I
sat down and and he just basically told
me like I don't want to wait I don't
want to wait for an engagement and a
long engagement
I just want to get married
um
and I had been told most of my life that
you know my role
in the group and just generally speaking
was you know to be a wife and a mother
um you know
we were not encouraged to think about
school think about careers anything like
that
um
and
so I you know I did what I have been
told my entire life to do which was to
just obey and do as I was told and
um I met him that morning and I was
forced into a spiritual wedding with him
that night how old are you I was uh 15
years old
and he was 28 so he was 13 years older
than me
in the state of California that is
considered to be statutory rape
um my I was not allowed to talk to my
mom I didn't have like a cell phone or
anything at that time uh you know we
just had these little pagers and I
didn't have one
um
and
um so that night I was I was I was
forced to marry him in a spiritual
wedding ceremony you know nobody put a
gun to my head nobody
you know say oh this is like you have to
do this otherwise you know we're gonna
like string you up and beat you
um but they didn't have to do that to me
my I was deathly afraid of my father and
I thought what I was doing was right
um that's what I had been told to do my
entire life
and um and so I I thought you know what
I was doing was right and it was gonna
save me and um you know I was going to
be a good person after that and
um then they just
physically handed me over to this guy
after that
after that ceremony
and um
he was he was able to leave the country
with me shortly after
um
he didn't write me on my wedding night
he raped me the day after
and
then continued to do so
throughout the rest of our marriage
so I immediately was pregnant he took me
out of the country
for about six months
where I did not speak the language
um
I didn't know anybody there and I was
just completely dependent on him
and so I you know I think a part of me
uh you know I've struggled a long time
with this but I think a part of me just
kind of turned off
and I just you know I just fully went
into being a wife you know and um
I I um when I was about six months
pregnant we came back to the states of
the Bay Area
and we were legally married in Reno
Nevada which is just a short four-hour
drive from where we were living
and um in a drive-through wedding chapel
somebody you know rubber stamped my my
wedding certificate
and at the time all it took in Nevada in
the state of Nevada was a permission
slip from one parent
that was notarized
um
I don't ever remember being asked if I
consented although even if I was asked I
probably would have said yes
um
because at that point I was extremely
traumatized I was I was his property
basically
um and you were brainwashed
oh it was definitely brainwashed
my entire life I mean that's what this
is it's taken me a year it's taken me
this long too I'm brainwashed myself
you could call it that but uh yeah I'm
like still dealing with the the washing
of the brain
um
but uh I'm sorry where was I uh so he
so we were we were legally married in
Reno Nevada the only the one thing that
I do remember about that trip was that I
really wanted to go sledding because you
know I had grown up in Colorado early
and I missed the snow and I I just
wanted to go sledding with my big ass
pregnant belly
I wanted to go sledding and we did and I
mean that's that's where my brain was
like I I was kid I was definitely a kid
still what I didn't realize when I when
I did legally get married is that I was
signing all of my rights away so you
were pregnant at the wedding I was
pregnant it was not a wedding it was
again it was just drive through wedding
chapel
um but you weren't supposed to be
having sex before you were no that they
should have called the cops
because that was clear evidence but
according to the cult you're not
supposed to have sex before marriage
um well I was I was spiritually married
at 15 right
so in the eyes of of God uh you know I
that was perfectly okay after my
spiritual ceremony that's when I was
handed over to this guy so
um for all purposes for my dad basically
that was like you know that was that was
the Real Marriage the the uh the formal
wedding certificate was a way for any of
them to get out of any type of charges
statutory rape child sexual assault
kidnapping all those things which they
could have been charged with no longer
applied the day that they stamp my
wedding certificate
so up until then I wasn't allowed to
even really talk to my mom
um
I you know I remember
the day after my
ex-abuser raped me he stood over
the phone and had me call my mom and lie
to her and say that I was going to live
with my dad now I didn't want to live
with her anymore
I mean I still had all my stuff at her
house
I
I never got to go back to my mom's house
I never got to go back to being a kid
that that one night just took away my
entire childhood I I could never
I guess I'm still looking for
for myself
um
so yeah that was my that was my that was
my wedding
um that was my wedding story
um
that was how old do you know I am
me too
crying about this [__] um how have you
how did you get out get away from this
um it took me it took me about 10 years
I ended up having two children
with my ex and I I had my daughter
when I was 16.
and she literally changed my entire
world
I just didn't know what how I was going
to leave but I did know that there was
something wrong slowly slowly I started
to realize there was something wrong I
think what I had told myself for a long
time was that you know I was
I was doing this to be a good a good
a follower a good daughter and slowly
that like started changing in my brain I
I remember taking my daughter to the
park one day and just seeing like other
kids my age walking to school and just
thinking to myself I need to I want to
go back to school I want to be like
those kids you know and I asked my ex
and
he said oh we'll go ask you know go ask
the Shake's wife so I went to ask the
shake his wife and she basically just
kind of put me down and said no you know
you're supposed to be a wife and a
mother
um
you know
what is your husband gonna feel like if
you're working or if you start going to
school he might feel like less of a man
um you know your place is in the home
and it was then at that point that I was
just like no I
I didn't want to listen to her and um
and so I I decided to disobey
and I started going back to school in
Fremont Fremont adult school and I got
my GED and then I had to find my own
child care so
how far were you allowed to go to school
before this uh
change your life
before before I was able to leave yeah
no before before you got pregnant and
married and all that
I was allowed to go to school
forced Mary
there's like 15 freshman freshman year I
finished my freshman year of high school
and then
I was taken out of school which happens
to a lot of
victims of child marriage they get taken
out of school because they're now having
kids
and so I couldn't go back to like
regular high school with a kid and
everything
um you have two children now I have two
children now yeah what happened to your
kids they're they're with me my kids are
with me they're in their 20s
um yeah they're still with me I'm trying
they're doing good though um
and uh my daughter's in school
um for fashion she's really into
textiles and my son is
um he works in cyber security
their father is
he's not in the picture I mean he is but
not I mean not really how are you able
to put yourself away from this how many
years were you so I went back to school
took me
seven years eventually to leave him I
was 23 and by that time I had gotten my
associate's degree in culinary arts I
decided to start working as a chef and
um
I started working and the first paycheck
that I got I'll never forget I was like
I want to I want to go out to dinner and
I'm gonna pay because you know our
entire marriage I um he was extremely
abusive around money I just
any time I spent money it was just like
long interrogations about what I spent
money on and this and that and very
controlling around the money so like for
once I I was like oh I have money I'm
gonna you know take us out to dinner I
don't have to hear anybody like telling
me that I can't afford to pay this and
this and that and
um so we did that when he when we got
home he was very angry
um which was pretty normal for him but
you know this time he was really angry
and uh I was done I was done and I took
my I just remember taking my ring off
and throwing it on the ground and like I
I want to you know I want a divorce and
um
he at first you know I I had just
started working I had never
had a bank account I I just learned to
drive when I was like 22 years old
so
I had to figure out you know how was I
gonna
how was I going to survive with two kids
now so he said okay I'm gonna take the
kids and you know you figure it out and
then you'll uh
I'll bring them back at the end of the
summer
so he left with the kids and I kept
working I rented a place
and um
I got them enrolled in school and
time came for the kids to come back home
he called me and said the kids aren't
coming back to live with you
I said no way that's not going to happen
because
that's what happened to me and I did not
want that to happen to my kids so I
called my brother he lends me eight
hundred dollars
travel to get my kids
brought them back home with me
and I filed for a divorce
that's
that's when I started you know
that's when I started to live my life
again
it took three years to get a divorce
it's a very extremely complicated family
law you know process anybody who's gone
through a divorce will tell you that as
a minor you can't you can't even hire an
attorney
to get a divorce
because you're a minor
you cannot go to a shelter you cannot
enter into a lease because in the eyes
of the law you are not considered an
adult even if you're married you become
legally emancipated here in the state of
California however that is not going to
help you when you go into an attorney's
office and you're like I need to hire an
attorney because I want to get a divorce
that attorney I guarantee you a thousand
percent because I did my Master's thesis
on it will tell you
sorry kid I can't help you
the family law system is not
made for minors to navigate it and so it
creates extreme barriers for minors who
want to leave their forced marriage and
so that is why now I advocate to change
the laws and
um it it took me a long time to leave it
took me three years to get that divorce
finalized was there a fight oh there was
a fight he tried to assault and kill me
during that divorce that was the that
was the first time he had ever tried to
kill me and the last
um
and he you know he was he came out
because he had to hire an attorney
I
um I didn't have the money to hire an
attorney so I went to uh the family I
went to Legal Aid
and they just helped me with the the
paperwork
so I I didn't have any representation
but he did and I took him to see my
son's preschool while he came out to for
a visit and on the way home he tried to
throw me out of a moving vehicle
and I remember holding my phone in my
hand trying to call the police he took
my phone and threw it out the window the
kids were screaming in the back
and um
and after that incident I just never saw
him alone again after that
um and thankfully I didn't have to I I
divorced him
it took me
it took me over 10 years to
I want to say catch up to where my peers
were but I still don't ever feel like I
will ever
catch up just because
I wanted to go to law school I wanted to
be a lawyer I had
hopes and dreams for my life
that we're just completely taken away
from me
at 15 years old
and that's why I advocate to end child
marriage here in the United States
and internationally it's it's an issue
in the United States that you know
people
they don't know about
thank you
they think
that this is they think that child
marriage happens
well they they have a lot of
they have a lot of ideas about what they
think child marriage is
a lot of what I get is oh well that just
happens you know in your culture right
um you know you were you were a Muslim
that happens to Muslims no it doesn't
just happen to Muslims it happens in all
religions it happens without religion
women and girls are forced into
relationships every single [__] day
you look around women are women and
girls are getting forced into into all
kinds of relationships whether they like
it or not
and the same goes for boys
there doesn't have to be religion
involved and in fact people use religion
to cover up this abuse they use religion
to cover up pedophilia
no religion in the world allows for
pedophilia
that's
that's ridiculous
my dad and his group hid behind their
so-called religion used it to their
advantage to cover up the abuse of
children not just me
a lot of the girls most of the girls my
age
they were forced to get married to older
adult men the Sheikh basically said you
know marry them young marry them when
they're virgins
he would uh you know these guys would
join the group
um give money to the Sheikh next thing
you know they're getting married to
teenagers
so what do you call that that's a
trafficking ring that's what that is
it took me this long to figure that out
it took me a long long long time to
figure that out it wasn't until 2017
when I was going back I'm sorry
2014.
back up to when my mom died
because my mom even though she was an
alcoholic even though she was definitely
addicted to drugs
my mom loved me
she was the one adult in my life who
loved me so much
even if it was hard for her to take care
of me
even if it was hard for her to be there
for me she was there when I really
needed her
um
I was working as a chef and barely
making ends meet
I called my mom and I told her I needed
to change careers I needed to go back to
school she said bring the kids here and
I will I will help you you can go back
to school
and that's what I did I spent two years
getting my paralegal degree I started
working
for the county
that allowed me to have a stable job
and slowly slowly I started rebuilding
my life
I went back to school
again in 2016 after my mom passed away
she always told me look the time is
going to pass
just finish your education you know you
you can do it just she always encouraged
me and um
she was the reason I really started
going back to school and trying to
finish my bachelor's degree and in 2017
I was doing a research project for an
English class and I I was thinking to
myself oh you know maybe I'm just like
an anomaly maybe our group it's an
anomaly this doesn't happen regularly to
other kids right so I start researching
this issue myself
found out that in 2017 all 50 states
allowed child marriage to happen
basically what Most states do is they
set the age at 18 and then they allow
for exceptions so California as an
example
has no age floor
you can get married here in California
at zero years old with parental consent
and judicial review
now why aren't parental consent and
judicial review not enough it's not a
high enough standard why because we know
that children can get easily coerced
abused into a relationship by their
parents by their own family
so who's going to protect the kid
then the kid cannot even leave the
marriage because again they're not
considered an adult under the eyes of
the law so they're now stuck in in a
marriage that they cannot Escape
and I found out that at that time all 50
states allowed it and I was
I was like so shocked I I couldn't
believe what I was what I was reading
and I found some non-profit
organizations that were doing work
um
to create awareness that this is
happening I found out that it was
happening frequently all over the United
States why because it's allowed it's
legally allowed it protects the abuser
from any type of uh you know legal
repercussions so you know it protected
my abuser from statutory rape charges
from kidnapping charges from child
sexual assault assault charges you name
it
he was protected who wasn't protected me
I wasn't protected not even when I filed
for divorce was I protected
so
you know I I reached out to this
non-profit
and they immediately got got in touch
with me and they said
we want to know more about your story
and would you be interested in in
talking about this publicly because you
know a lot of survivors they have a hard
time talking about this subject it's
extremely traumatizing it's
re-traumatizing and and
um you know
we need folks to raise awareness of it
so I started working on the issue then
and basically what I do now is I work
alongside non-profit organizations
um I I testify at legislative hearings
there's one coming up in Washington
state by the way anybody who's in
Washington state
and I share my personal story
so that people can understand what the
abuses are
that hide under child marriage
under these laws
that are protecting
abusers and
and exposing minors to all kinds of
abuse
miners who get married are three times
more likely to be abused within their
marriage domestic domestic violence
happens three times more
they
are usually pulled out of school
and the landscape the people who this is
affecting today in the United States are
minors
there are minors who are girls being
forced into marriages with adult men
and there's a lot of studies out there I
would
I would urge everybody who is watching
this to go out and do your own research
find out what those numbers are in your
state
is it allowed you know can minors be
forced into a marriage in your state and
I guarantee you they probably can since
2017 Six States have ended child
marriage
Six States because of the efforts of of
victim Advocates and because of the
efforts of non-profit organizations who
have brought this to the attention of
legislators in their states
and usually
um you know Survivor Advocates like me
will come forward share our stories in a
public hearing share our testimony and
people will be shocked and say how could
this happen how could this happen here
but I'm telling you now it's written
into into 46 States laws
it does not there are these laws on the
books that are blatantly trafficking our
minors
and it just has to change it has to
change
so so how difficult has it been for you
to recover from from what you went
through as a kid as a teen
I'm still recovering from you know from
what I went through
um
I I think recovery is not linear
um it is a circular process I started
going to therapy
after my mom died and I've been in
therapy on and off ever since then but
that is really what has helped me to
give vocabulary to what happened to me
because for the longest time even till
until today
I blame myself
I blame myself because
that's what people told me growing up
they said I was a bad kid they said I
was a very bad kid my entire life I was
told I was a bad child that I was evil
you know because of who my mom was
because I asked too many
freaking questions I was just I was just
too damn curious you know I was a bad
kid that's what they told me I believed
it I believed it I believed it up until
today like a part of me sometimes still
believes it and when I was forced to get
married at 15 I thought it was my fault
because I had a boyfriend
I knew that was wrong you know I was
told my whole life you can't you can't
even look at a man in their eyes
imagine you know
going to a basketball game with a boy
making out with them
you know they uh my dad of course
assumed that I was that I was having sex
I wasn't he didn't even bother to ask me
but I was blamed I was blamed for
everything that's my point is that I I
was blamed
for everything that happened to me and I
believed that story in my head and
that's what kept me quiet for so many
years that's what kept me from from
talking to the adults around me because
even going to the doctor
I remember when I was pregnant with my
daughter
even going to the doctor I was told this
is the story that you're going to give
okay
um
and a part of me believed that story
and so in order to recover
you you have to unravel that in your
brain
and for me I mean there's lots of ways
to recover okay there's not just one way
to recover I I you know going for a walk
is recovery
getting your mind to to focus and try to
work through that pain
without drugs without alcohol
you know there was a time when I was
when I did start drinking and I had to
make that choice
is this the path that I want to go down
I saw about that path I saw the end of
that path I saw my mom pass away
from addiction
I see what it does to families
my own family you know
a lot of people struggling with
addiction because of what happened to us
when we were kids
and if you let that pain just
eat away at you
it will it will eat you up
that hate that rage whatever it is that
you're struggling with that will eat you
you have to get help for it you got to
process it
and
as hard as as as it is to go through
those emotions I do it because I want to
be able to connect with my kids I want
to have those conversations with them I
want to talk to my husband
he supports me so much I want to be able
to open up to him and talk to him about
this stuff
it's not easy but
you know therapy has helped
and you're doing a good job with your
kids now
um you're living a very different job
than you do my kids have grown up with a
completely different childhood they are
very much in control of who they are
they know you know they may not have it
all figured out that's for sure but they
definitely are their own people and
they're very unique and I never ever
ever wanted them to be exposed to
anything like that and it would they
were a huge part of my reason for for
wanting to talk out about this
and even though you know my kids have a
hard time with this because
you know obviously that's their dad and
uh
you know it's it's hard for them to hear
this stuff
but they're the reason I I try to make
this change
um I love my kids with all my heart I
would do anything for them and and and I
want them to live in a better world
that's that's why I do this
um so they're they're just my reason
they're my reason for everything
they're my heart
Sarah thank you so much for sharing your
story thank you
thank you super interesting thank you